4 46 on your monday morning here's a
shout out to everyone involved in the
miz senior golden years pageant i had
the honor of being one of the judges
over the weekend in trump
the 2021 miss senior golden year's marla
cuercia said her formal goodbye i am so
grateful for this honor and chance to
give back to my beautiful community of
peru one of the other judges got on
stage to entertain salve vargas edelman
[Music]
all six contestants appeared in
swimsuits
but swimsuits like their grandmothers
would have worn
and soon m.c stephanie elliott made the
announcement your
2022 miss senior golden years usa
[Applause]
ellie will susan now all the contestants
have to be at least 60 years young want
to give a special shout out to the
pageant president bj hetrick sheet just
turned 97.
fellow judge bruce jabor a night county
commissioner it was a ton of fun out
there at the saddle west casino
and a huge crowd
people get so into it and it's a ton of
fun congratulations how many years have
you done this now
uh it's only been four or five okay it
feels like more yeah no because it's
just such a cool deal it seems like it's
been around for a long time i can't it
just seems like you just did the pageant
i think it was a little later last year
because of the pandemic exactly i think
it was in september so now they're kind
of getting it back on their normally in
june or july okay all right the ladies
had time to practice their talent and
their swimsuit goodness they had a
roaring 20s theme
and they were wearing flapper outfits oh
my gosh